we haven't seen Mass Effect Andromeda
since its announcement at e3 2015 and
with the recent delay into 2017 that's
not likely to change anytime soon but
here's the good news a few eager fans
may have dug up some images of what
appears to be the game's main character
the scans were found at ZBrush central a
forum for artists and 3d modelers to
show off their work fans say this may be
the new lead character known as the
Pathfinder the name stamped in the
corner is Herbert Louis the lead artist
at Bioware Montreal but considering the
forum is full of artists it could easily
be a hoax the image does look good but
take it with a grain of salt this is the
first Mass Effect game not starring the
beloved Commander Shepard so if this
character is legit it's someone
completely new ea confirmed that Mass
Effect Andromeda is launching in 2017 so
stay tuned for more from GameSpot I'm
Tony you can follow me on twitter at
Chengguan Pope and I'm just hoping I'll
get to romance Holly again